good morning believe nation today's
message is do one thing over to you
Robert Rodriguez there's this book
called the one thing we've seen that
says you should just do one thing then I
go well I shouldn't even bother reading
that that doesn't apply to me but I
thought about it it's like well I do one
thing I live a creative life everything
you do you apply creativity to it
whether it's the way you meet with a
friend and make them dinner or your do
stuff with your kids and then when you
go and you're you're working on an idea
and you're doing music at the same time
while you're on the set and you're
you're never in a block because you're
always actually in a flow if you don't
live your life creatively and then you
set aside some time at night to go write
your novel you're going to get a block
because you're not in the flow but if
you apply creativity to everything in
your life everything is available to you
to where you suddenly can paint like
you'll see paintings I did with the
actors even though they're very creative
in the acting world they didn't think
they could paint so I made them paint
and then they saw that they were able to
because when you're in a creative flow
you can do just about anything so it's
all about living a creative life to
where you can't possibly ever get
blocked because you're always okay well
I mean I have an idea for writing so I'm
gonna go cook something which is art you
can eat you know and you're serving and
you're eating to consume in it and
you're creating and you go back and you
do that does that make sense of the way
there's no structure boxes around
there's no like no like alienation of
doing work and play it's all play this
is why it's so important to find your
one word because it's not just about
doing one thing one task it's about
living one way your way on purpose and
knowing what that is so if I look at
this clip as an example Roberts one word
is likely creative right he wants to be
creative he wants to live in the
creative way it's not just doing one
task all day long but doing creative
work all day long that's where he comes
alive and if you tried to put Robert in
a room with no doors and no windows and
just lock him in there in the cell and
told him what to do he would die if you
starved all the creativity out of him
and forced him to do something he would
hate it he would struggle nobody would
know who he was
and that's most people most people have
no idea who they are and are stuck in a
box that somebody else has made for them
and they don't know how to get out they
don't know what their one word is they
don't know how to break free they don't
know how to design a life on purpose
it's why it's so important to understand
what the one word is for you that now
you can create something and design it a
life and the business Iran what you want
to do so let's look at creativity let's
look at Robert a little bit more all the
people that he surrounds himself with
should be people who help them be more
creative all the content that he
consumes on a daily basis I don't know
what his habits are is he reading books
is he watching YouTube videos is he
checking out the news is he going to
theatres is he going to the movies like
the content that he consumes should make
him feel more creative his daily habits
and rituals whatever that looks like
whether it's meditation or doing yoga or
you know watching some YouTube videos
watching an espresso in the morning
those things should be designed to help
him be more creative and so once you
understand what the one word is for you
what the one way is for you when you
figure that out then you look at your
life you look at what your typical
weekly schedule looks like you look at
the things that you're consuming on a
daily basis you look at the people that
you're hanging around with constantly
and how many of those people activities
and things help that one way help that
one word come out of you and for a lot
of people at the start it's a really
sobering experience for a lot of people
like if you're unhappy with your life if
you feel like you have a huge ceiling
and you're not anywhere close to
reaching your potential it's because a
lot of the people things and habits that
you have on a daily basis
are not coming out they're suppressing
you they're keeping you in your box and
it starts because you don't even
the self-awareness to know what your one
word is you don't have the
self-awareness to know what the one
thing is that you should be doing but
the one way of living is that you should
be living so figure it out then do an
audit of your life
and the habits and the things that are
around you say does this help me believe
more or create more or care more it's
the unlock it gives you certainty it
gives you clarity it gives you power and
unless you do amazing things so the
question of the day today is I'm curious
what is the one way that you want to
live what is the one word core value for
you and once you figure that out what's
one thing that you need to start
changing what's the one thing in your
life that does not support you being
creative or believing or caring more and
you need to eliminate that funeral life
super curious to find out leave it down
the comments below and we'll join in the
discussion I also want to give a quick
shout out to Peter oh gee Peter thank
you so much for picking up a cup of my
book your one word I really really
really appreciate the support
thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is and I'll see you again
tomorrow morning for another shot event
spresso
[Music]